well now that Shrek's dead and buried
what to do now well spin-off of course
you need to ask puss-in-boots first when
I heard that they were making a Puss in
Boots movie I was like alright spin-off
from a character from Shrek actually a
character from fairy tales that was also
in Shrek but you know the one from Shrek
so we'll see how it goes I saw the
trailer and I was still like we'll see
how it goes it looks like it's fun but
we'll see so the question is how is Puss
in Boots as its own movie can the
character Puss in Boots hold a movie on
his own and yeah he really can't I
thought this movie was really fun I mean
he got Puss in Boots and he's a great
character I thought it was the best
thing that ever happened to Shrek he's
voiced by Antonio Banderas so he's like
Zorro but the cat and they make fun of
all the fun little nuances that cats do
which is funny because cats are
ridiculous things ridiculous but cute
almost as cute as that Plus Joker I got
at Target that's the best but just like
Shrek you're gonna see a few characters
and Puss in Boots that our fairy tale
characters you've heard of them before
and they tie in with the plot and I
really thought that was cool Puss in
Boots carries on that tradition but
again in its own way
I thought Puss in Boots was great as a
standalone movie because the style is so
different than Shrek I mean yeah I still
had the fairy tale stuff like I just
said but it has this whole like you know
1800 Spanish Mexico vibe in that really
cool music you know like Zorro music you
know dedenne didn't didn't down that's
legit and I thought the humor was really
good too the thing about humor it's all
about the timing
you would think no dub it's amazing how
many people don't know that and humor
it's all about the comedic timing Puss
in Boots has a pretty good comedic
timing couple parts in particular they
were funny there's no part in this movie
that made me laugh to tears like you
know you're laughing so hard you can't
breathe and you're crying they never
happened to me in puss and boots but it
was still a funny movie
I enjoyed the movie that I walked out
and I was like this movie's better than
the last two Shrek movies easily
although I already said it didn't feel
like Shrek so I shouldn't compare it to
Shrek but I'm just saying I walked out
going yet better than Shrek 3 & 4 so
it's funny it's enjoyable it's good fun
for the whole family has those jokes
that adults are gonna get but kids
aren't quite gonna get or maybe they
will I don't know but it wasn't like
infantile humor you know it wasn't like
oh oh girl that's funny
which is what Shrek became so it was a
whole fresh new feel it's its own thing
it's a standalone movie that stands
alone perfectly if you've never seen any
of the Shrek movies you can still go
into post and boots and be like oh
that's great I will say it's a good time
no alcohol or shot glasses filled with
milk required and 3d was great too I
thought this was some of the best 3d
I've seen in a long time so props to
DreamWorks on that DreamWorks has always
had good 3d
so you see puss-in-boots how do you
think it's stacked up to the Shrek
movies and actually what's your favorite
Antonio Banderas character he's played a
lot of characters so I think it's a fair
question comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more didn't
[Music]